Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The representatives of the French people formed into a national assembly and considering ignorance, forgetfulness or contempt of the rights of man to be the only causes of public misfortunes and the corruption of governments have resolved to set forth in a solemn declaration the natural, unalienable, and sacred rights of man, to the end that this declaration, constantly present to all members of the body politic, may remind them unceasingly of their rights and their duties. The duties. Who saw that coming? So, Tom, that is the preamble to the declaration of the rights
感谢收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。法国人民的代表们组成国民议会，考虑到对人权的无知、遗忘或蔑视是造成公共不幸和政府腐败的唯一原因，决定通过一项庄严的宣言，阐明人自然、不可剥夺和神圣的权利，以便使这一宣言不断呈现在政治共同体所有成员面前，不断提醒他们自己的权利和义务。义务。谁能想到这一点？所以，汤姆，这就是《人权宣言》的序言。
of man and of the citizen. I'm now rethinking everything I thought about the French Revolution because Margaret Thatcher in our first episode told us they forgot about the duties, but they didn't. I'm in shock. Only in the preamble, though, they'd forgot about the duties. But they didn't. I'm in shock. Only in the preamble, though, they didn't include the duties in the list of rights that follow that. Oh, that is the giveaway. So people who are wondering what we're talking about, that is the preamble to the Declaration of the Rights of Man and the Citizen, one of the landmark documents in all human history. It was approved by the National Assembly on the 26th of August 1789.
以及公民权宣言。我现在正在重新思考我对法国大革命的所有看法，因为玛格丽特·撒切尔夫人在我们的第一集中告诉我们，他们忘记了义务，但他们并没有。我感到震惊。不过，这只是在序言中，他们忘记了义务。但他们并没有。我感到震惊。不过，这只是在序言中，他们没有在随后的权利清单中包含义务。哦，这就是破绽。所以，对于那些想知道我们在谈论什么的人，这就是《人权和公民权宣言》的序言，这是人类历史上最具里程碑意义的文件之一。它于1789年8月26日获得国民议会批准。
And Tom, they had been talking about it for about a month, hadn't they? This document that now we all think of as so tremendously important. Why did they feel they needed it? Well, you say that it's a document that we're all familiar with. I'm not entirely confident in the English speaking world that that's the case. You mentioned Mrs. Thatcher. We looked at the beginning about how she talked about how the French Revolution, the ideals, the values, the principles, all these were already evident in Britain's glorious revolution and the kind of the Whiggish tradition of parliamentary democracy and all that. And I think also for American listeners, they will be thinking of the Declaration of Independence, that the Declaration of Independence came first. And I think for that reason that
汤姆，他们已经讨论了一个月了，不是吗？这份我们现在都认为极其重要的文件。为什么他们觉得需要它呢？嗯，你说这是一份我们都很熟悉的文件。我不确定在英语世界里是否真的如此。你提到了撒切尔夫人。我们在开头谈到了她是如何谈论法国大革命的，那些理想、价值观、原则，所有这些在英国的光荣革命以及辉格党传统的议会民主制中都已经显而易见。而且我认为对于美国听众来说，他们会想到《独立宣言》，认为《独立宣言》在前。我认为正是因为这个原因，
English speakers tend perhaps, and I certainly speak for myself, it doesn't tend to kind of dominate my imaginings in the way that I think it does certainly for the French, but also for people across the world. Because I think until this point, Dominic, in the previous episode, you portrayed the fall of the Bastille as a story of bloodshed and kind of violence. Yeah. And you've shown your respect for this totemic declaration of human rights by putting on a comedy French accent. Yeah.
英语使用者可能倾向于——我当然是代表我自己——它并不像我认为的那样主导我的想象，当然对法国人来说是这样，对世界各地的人来说也是如此。因为我认为直到这一点，多米尼克，在上一集中，你把巴士底狱的陷落描绘成一个充满流血和暴力的故事。是的。而且你通过模仿滑稽的法国口音，表达了你对这份图腾般的人权宣言的尊重。是的。
But I think the French Revolution is a story of ideals and principles and values. And that's not to say that there isn't incredible violence. There obviously is. I think that the violence and the idealism are intertwined. They're interfused. It's impossible to understand the one without the other. And so if you just emphasize the violence without saying, you know, there are a lot of abstract nouns that people take very, very seriously, then I think you're missing out on both why the French Revolution happens in the way that it does. And also, of course, very importantly, the enduring legacy right the way into the present day.
但我认为法国大革命是一个关于理想、原则和价值观的故事。这并不是说没有令人难以置信的暴力。显然是有的。我认为暴力和理想主义是交织在一起的。它们是融合在一起的。如果不理解其中之一，就不可能理解另一个。所以，如果你只强调暴力而不说，你知道，人们非常非常认真地对待许多抽象名词，那么我认为你既错过了法国大革命发生的原因，也错过了它对当今世界产生的深远影响。
I think that's fair enough, Tom, because the violence is driven by belief in the abstract now, right? It's not violence for its own sake. I mean, sometimes it may be, but people genuinely believe in the ideology they're preaching. And that ideology, I mean, it gives them a faith, I suppose, that what they're doing is right. We will be exploring the degree to which it's a faith over the course of this episode. Yes. Because I think that for admirers of the French Revolution, and of course, for the French state as well, it is the great manifesto.
我认为这很公平，汤姆，因为暴力是由对抽象事物的信仰所驱动的，对吧？这不是为了暴力而暴力。我的意思是，有时可能是这样，但人们确实相信他们所宣扬的意识形态。那种意识形态，我的意思是，它给了他们一种信仰，我想，他们所做的是正确的。在本集节目中，我们将探讨这种信仰的程度。是的。因为我认为对于法国大革命的崇拜者，当然也包括法国政府来说，它是伟大的宣言。
And it's completely seismic in its implications and its influence. And actually, in France, its significance is explicitly acknowledged to this day in the preamble to the constitution of the Fifth Republic, the current kind of republic. And if you think about all those world leaders who, in the bicentenary of the French Revolution in 1989, who weren't Mrs. Thatcher, they were all praising the revolution for the values that they said it upheld, the kind of the liberal, secular, egalitarian values. And they were able to do that because, as you mentioned at the end of the previous episode, these values, although they are specifically French, they are also cast as universal. And so the French Revolution is able to cast itself as a fire that
它的影响和意义是完全震撼性的。实际上，在法国，它的重要性至今仍明确体现在第五共和国（即当前的共和国）宪法的序言中。如果你想想1989年法国大革命二百周年纪念时，那些不是撒切尔夫人的世界领导人，他们都在赞扬这场革命所坚持的价值观，即那种自由、世俗、平等的价值观。他们之所以能这样做，是因为正如你在上一集结尾提到的，这些价值观虽然是法国特有的，但也被视为普世的。因此，法国大革命能够将自己塑造成一团火，
has illumined the entire world. And so the Declaration of the Rights of Man and the Citizen has been massively influential on other republican constitutions around the world. And I think preeminently on the UN's Universal Declaration of Human Rights, which was adopted very tellingly, I think in 1949 in Paris. So you can see why enthusiasts for the Declaration of the Rights of Man and of the Citizen make very high claims for it indeed. So I'll just read you what Jonathan Israel in his book on the French Revolution, Revolutionary Ideas, says. And Jonathan Israel is the great enthusiast and proponent of the notion that the French Revolution kind of emerges from what he calls the radical enlightenment, the enlightenment of atheism, of radical hostility to monarchy and religion and so on. And he says, talking about the Declaration of the Rights of Man,
照亮了整个世界。因此，《人权和公民权宣言》对世界各地的其他共和宪法产生了巨大的影响。我认为最突出的是联合国《世界人权宣言》，它非常耐人寻味地于1949年在巴黎通过。所以你可以明白为什么《人权和公民权宣言》的拥护者对它评价如此之高。我来读一下乔纳森·以色列在他的法国大革命著作《革命思想》中所说的话。乔纳森·以色列是那种认为法国大革命源于他所谓的“激进启蒙运动”——即无神论、对君主制和宗教的激进敌意等——这一观点的伟大拥护者和倡导者。他在谈到《人权宣言》时说，
for the first time in history, equality, individual liberty, the right to equal protection by the state, and freedom of thought and expression were enshrined as basic principles declared inherent in all just and rational societies. The bedrock of democratic modernity was in place. What do you make of that, Dominic? Well, that's the counter-argument, isn't it, to the slightly Burkean argument. Edmund Burke's
“历史上第一次，平等、个人自由、国家平等保护的权利以及思想和表达自由被确立为所有公正和理性社会所固有的基本原则。民主现代性的基石已经奠定。”多米尼克，你对此有何看法？嗯，这就是对稍微带有伯克色彩的论点的反驳，不是吗？埃德蒙·伯克的
argument is Reflections on the Revolution in France, which was published even before the terror. Burke said this is terrible, throwing out traditions and customs. You'll be left with anarchy and horror. And even at the time, there were a lot of people who said to Burke, you are missing the fact that this will genuinely bring in a new world, a liberal world, governed by freedom and by the expression of human reason. And that's effectively what Jonathan Israel is arguing, isn't it? I think in the fundamentals, yes. So before we get onto the abstract nouns, which we will be looking at, because I think they are so important to understanding the course of
论点是《对法国大革命的反思》，该书在恐怖时期之前就已经出版了。伯克说这太可怕了，抛弃了传统和习俗。你们将陷入无政府状态和恐怖之中。即使在当时，也有很多人对伯克说，你忽略了一个事实，那就是这确实会带来一个新世界，一个自由的世界，由自由和人类理性的表达所统治。这实际上就是乔纳森·以色列所争论的，不是吗？我认为在基本面上，是的。所以在我们进入抽象名词之前——我们将要研究这些名词，因为我认为它们对于理解革命的进程非常重要——
the revolution, should we just go back and remind ourselves where we were? Yes, where are we? So we've got the National Assembly, which is the conflation of what had previously been the three estates. Now, the National Assembly is the embodiment of the will and the sovereignty of the people. The Bastille has fallen. The first émigrés have fled. And Louis, who has not fled, is trying to reinvent himself as a constitutional monarch. But while all this is going on, everything that
我们是否应该回顾一下我们所处的位置？是的，我们在哪里？所以我们有了国民议会，它是之前三个等级的合并。现在，国民议会是人民意志和主权的体现。巴士底狱已经陷落。第一批流亡者已经逃离。而没有逃离的路易十六，正试图将自己重塑为一位立宪君主。但当这一切发生时，所有
precipitated the revolution, so chiefly the fact that there's no money and that the bread price is very high, that hasn't really changed. Yeah. So there's still an atmosphere of panic and crisis, isn't there? So here's the thing. Why are the deputies who are in the National Assembly, why would they spend all their time talking about a declaration of human rights when you would think their priority would be you know to be discussing bread supplies or whatever it might be because i think that most of the deputies who had assembled at versailles in may 1789 so for the estates general that then becomes the national assembly i mean they they thought that they had come there to give france a new constitution And I think they operate on the assumption that you can't remedy the ills facing France unless you have set the country on new foundations. And the Declaration of Rights is an attempt to frame for both the delegates
促成革命的事情，主要是没有钱和面包价格非常高，并没有真正改变。是的。所以仍然有一种恐慌和危机的气氛，不是吗？所以问题是：为什么国民议会的代表们要花所有时间讨论人权宣言，而你本以为他们的优先事项应该是讨论面包供应或其他什么呢？因为我认为大多数在1789年5月聚集在凡尔赛的代表——即后来成为国民议会的三级会议——他们认为他们来到那里是为了给法国制定一部新宪法。我认为他们的假设是，除非你为国家奠定新的基础，否则你无法补救法国面临的弊病。而《人权宣言》是试图为代表们
themselves, but also for all the people of France, an understanding of what henceforward will be animating the new France. And I think that that is actually an understanding that is turbocharged by the fall of the Bastille. Because you were saying how the people in the National Assembly are actually perturbed by what happens. They're unsettled by it. And actually, I'm right in saying, aren't I, that as the weeks go by, so during the time they're thinking about this, the news coming in, not so much from Paris, but from the countryside countryside is more alarming than ever and arguably more alarming than ever before in French history, because this is the year of
自己，也为法国所有人民，勾勒出一种对未来将推动新法国发展的理解。我认为这种理解实际上是被巴士底狱的陷落所涡轮增压的。因为你刚才说国民议会里的人实际上对发生的事情感到不安。他们对此感到动摇。而且我没说错吧，随着几周过去，在他们思考这个问题的时候，传来的消息，与其说是来自巴黎，不如说是来自乡村，比以往任何时候都更令人震惊，可以说在法国历史上是前所未有的，因为这是
what historians call la grande peur, the great fear. So this is coming in from the provinces. Yeah. I mean, I think there's hope as well as fear. So we've already mentioned him, Arthur Young, this Englishman who's gone on a trip across France. Yeah. An ill-timed holiday. Yeah, an ill-timed trip. So he, two days before the fall of the Bastille, is in Lorraine and he meets a peasant woman. And he asks her, you know, how are you doing? And he writes what she said.
历史学家所说的“大恐慌”之年。所以这是从各省传来的。是的。我的意思是，我认为既有希望也有恐惧。所以我们已经提到了他，亚瑟·杨，这个去法国旅行的英国人。是的。一个时机不佳的假期。是的，一次时机不佳的旅行。所以，在巴士底狱陷落前两天，他在洛林遇到了一位农妇。他问她，你知道，你过得怎么样？他写下了她所说的话。
It was said at present that something was to be done by some great folks for such poor ones, but she did not know who nor how. But God send us better because property taxes and feudal dues are crushing us. And Arthur Young, as a kind of illustration of the way that the poor are being crushed by the weight on them, he assumes that this woman must be kind of 60 or 70, but he asks and she turns out to be 28. So, yeah. Oh no. But then the Bastille falls and that actually, it doesn't lessen the temperature in the countryside. It actually, you know, it sends it through the roof because people now start, they hear that one fortress has fallen, and they start to attack other citadels of authority, don't they?
“现在有人说，一些大人物要为像我们这样的穷人做点什么，但她不知道是谁，也不知道怎么做。但愿上帝保佑我们，因为财产税和封建税正在压垮我们。”亚瑟·杨作为穷人被重担压垮的一种例证，他以为这个女人大概有60或70岁了，但他一问，发现她才28岁。所以，是的。哦，不。但随后巴士底狱陷落了，这实际上并没有降低乡村的温度。它实际上让它彻底爆发了，因为人们现在开始听说一座堡垒已经陷落，他们开始攻击其他权威的堡垒，不是吗？
And they're burning the registers. Yeah, well, that's the key, I think. Yeah. I think the fall of the Bastille is reported as the fall of feudalism. And we, again, mentioned this in the previous episode, it's very peasants revolt. There's this idea that if you as a peasant can burn the registers and the charters that condemn you to work as a peasant, then you will be free. And so they start targeting chateaus and particularly abbeys and monasteries, which also, you know, as in the days of the peasant revolt, own large tracts of land. And this brings kind of feudal dues and tithes with them.
他们在烧毁登记册。是的，我认为这是关键。是的。我认为巴士底狱的陷落被报道为封建制度的终结。我们再次在上一集中提到了这一点，这非常像农民起义。有一种想法是，如果你作为一个农民，能够烧毁那些注定你作为农民劳作的登记册和特许状，那么你就会自由。所以他们开始瞄准城堡，特别是修道院，正如农民起义时期一样，它们也拥有大片土地。这带来了封建税和什一税。
So an example of an abbey that gets attacked is one in Burgundy called Sainazon. And this is completely leveled. And it belongs to a very distinguished local family, the family of Talleyrand-Périgord. And the best known member of this family is actually a bishop, the bishop of the local town of Houton. And he had basically become a bishop because his nurse had not been looking after him and drops him on the floor and it damages his foot when he's about three and the foot never heals. And so he grows up unable to fulfill the military destiny that otherwise would have been
所以一个被攻击的修道院的例子是勃艮第的塞纳宗。这被彻底夷为平地。它属于一个非常显赫的当地家族，塔列朗-佩里戈尔家族。这个家族最著名的成员实际上是一位主教，当地小镇奥坦的主教。他之所以成为主教，基本上是因为他的护士没有照顾好他，在他三岁左右时把他掉在地上，伤了他的脚，而那只脚从未痊愈。所以他长大后无法实现原本属于他的军事命运，
his as a kind of swaggering aristocrat. And so he has no choice but to go into the church, which is an absolute mismatch between his talents. Right. Because he's quite Marquis de Sade. I mean, he's not that bad, but he's a kind of cynic. He's a free thinker. He's definitely inclined to libertinism, I think it's fair to say. Yeah. But he is unbelievably able, kind of cunning operator, kind of almost the embodiment of the
作为一个傲慢的贵族。所以他别无选择，只能进入教会，这与他的才华完全不匹配。对吧。因为他很像萨德侯爵。我的意思是，他没那么坏，但他是一个愤世嫉俗者。他是一个自由思想家，我认为公平地说，他倾向于放荡主义。是的。但他是一个令人难以置信的能干、狡猾的操作者，几乎是
Machiavelli, isn't he? Yeah, totally wrong. Yeah. I mean, he's the great survivor of the revolution. The great survivor. So he gets elected as a member of the first estate. So that's the church to go to Versailles. And when he's there, rather than kind of bat for the church, he teams up with Mirabeau, who's the great spokesman for the third estate. And they are sat together kind of working out drafts for the Declaration of the Rights of Man as news from the provinces is coming in. And the news is very, very alarming if you have any commitment to the integrity of the nation. The whole country seems basically to be disintegrating.
马基雅维利的化身，不是吗？是的，完全错了。是的。我的意思是，他是革命中伟大的幸存者。伟大的幸存者。所以他作为第一等级的成员被选为去凡尔赛的代表。当他在那里时，他没有为教会效力，而是与米拉波合作，米拉波是第三等级的伟大发言人。当来自各省的消息传来时，他们坐在一起起草《人权宣言》。如果你对国家的完整性有任何承诺，这些消息是非常非常令人震惊的。整个国家似乎基本上正在瓦解。
And we talked about the importance of rumour and the anxiety of conspiracy in the context of the Bastille. This is exactly what's happening in the countryside as well. And there are kind of terrified stories that the aristocrats are deliberately setting out to starve or poison the poor. And if that sounds mad, again, this is a staple of plots in the Marquis de Sade's novels. This idea that aristocrats have nothing better to do than to kind of plot starvation and ruin for the entire country is clearly part of the kind of the climate of paranoia of the time. And even at this stage, there's a sort of,
我们谈到了在巴士底狱背景下谣言和阴谋焦虑的重要性。这正是乡村里正在发生的事情。有一些可怕的故事说，贵族们故意要饿死或毒害穷人。如果这听起来很疯狂，这又是萨德侯爵小说中情节的支柱。这种认为贵族除了策划整个国家的饥饿和毁灭之外别无他事的想法，显然是当时偏执气氛的一部分。即使在这个阶段，也有一种，
I don't know whether xenophobia is too strong a word, but there's a great fear of foreigners, isn't there? That there are foreign armies that are poised to attack at any moment, that there are foreign-sponsored bands of brigands. People attack foreigners, they attack Jews,-sponsored bands of brigands. People attack foreigners, they attack Jews, they're looking for scapegoats, and this sort of mad paranoia that there's somebody out there, maybe just over the hill, who's going to attack your town, burn your crops, steal all your food, all of that kind of stuff. And so the process of people
我不知道“仇外心理”这个词是否太强烈，但有一种对外国人的巨大恐惧，不是吗？有外国军队随时准备进攻，有外国资助的强盗团伙。人们攻击外国人，攻击犹太人，他们在寻找替罪羊，这种疯狂的偏执认为外面有人，也许就在山那边，要来攻击你的城镇，烧毁你的庄稼，偷走你所有的食物，所有这些东西。所以人们
then forming militias to guard against this fear, this will then get reported by a neighbouring community who will then see this militia as precisely what they've got to guard against this fear. This will then get reported by a neighbouring community, who will then see this militia as precisely what they've got to guard against. And so it has a kind of knock-on effect, that people are raising militias against the phantoms of militias. And so it goes on. And this is absolutely not what people want. People are not demanding a kind of the disintegration of the country. Actually, they want greater control. They want people who can sort this out and give them bread and give them security. And back in Versailles, the delegates are themselves stressed that they're unable to provide this. And they get caught up in the mood of panic themselves. And so the more radical among the deputies think, you know, we need to do something dramatic here that will
随后组建民兵来防范这种恐惧，这随后会被邻近社区报道，他们会把这支民兵视为他们必须防范的对象。这随后会被邻近社区报道，他们会把这支民兵视为他们必须防范的对象。所以它有一种连锁反应，人们在针对民兵的幻影组建民兵。就这样一直持续下去。这绝对不是人们想要的。人们并没有要求国家的瓦解。实际上，他们想要更强的控制。他们想要能解决这个问题、给他们面包并给他们安全的人。而在凡尔赛，代表们自己也感到压力，因为他们无法提供这些。他们自己也陷入了恐慌的情绪中。所以代表中更激进的人认为，你知道，我们需要在这里做一些戏剧性的事情，
reassure people that we're, you know, we're on their side. So one of them calls it a kind of magic. And this kind of magic happens on the evening of the 4th of August, 1789. And it's a time when the National Assembly is actually very thinly attended. It's the evening and a guy stands up who you mentioned, Dominic, in the previous episode, the Vicomte de Neuilly, the guy who comes in and reports the fall of the Bastille to the king. And he's a man who has a foot in both the kind of the royal and the revolutionary camps. So his mother is Madame Etiquette, who was the guide to Marie Antoinette, who is always kind of scolding her for breaking the etiquette and so on. Oh, right. Okay. The embodiment of the rules and regulations of the
让人们放心，我们站在他们这一边。所以其中一个人称之为一种“魔法”。这种魔法发生在1789年8月4日的晚上。当时国民议会的出席率非常低。那是晚上，一个你提到的家伙站了起来，多米尼克，在上一集中，维孔特·德·诺阿耶，那个进来向国王报告巴士底狱陷落的家伙。他是一个在皇室和革命阵营中都有立足点的人。所以他的母亲是“礼仪夫人”，她是玛丽·安托瓦内特的向导，总是责骂她打破礼仪等等。哦，对。好吧。宫廷规则和条例的化身。
court. Yeah, exactly. But he has served alongside Lafayette, who is his brother-in-law in the American Revolution. And when Cornwallis surrendered at Yorktown, he had been the official representative of France. I hate him already, Tom. Right. So he's interestingly positioned. And so he stands up and he says that the kingdom of France is floating between the complete destruction of society and a government which would be admired and followed throughout Europe. So in other words, we have to do something radical or it will be complete anarchy. And so the radical step he proposes is that all feudal obligations should be abolished, which of course essentially means
是的，完全正确。但他曾与拉法耶特并肩作战，拉法耶特是他在美国革命中的妹夫。当康沃利斯在约克镇投降时，他是法国的官方代表。汤姆，我已经讨厌他了。好吧。所以他的立场很有趣。他站起来说，法兰西王国正漂浮在社会彻底毁灭和一种将被整个欧洲钦佩和效仿的政府之间。换句话说，我们必须采取激进的行动，否则将是彻底的无政府状态。所以他提出的激进步骤是废除所有封建义务，这当然本质上意味着
that from that point on, people will not need to go around ransacking chateaus and abbeys. And the other thing which he proposes in a very kind of offhand manner is that everyone in the kingdom should pay taxes. And this is precisely the issue that had been inspiring people in the previous year to refuse to accept the king's kind of fiscal solution. This is the maddest thing, isn't it? This is the maddest aspect of this whole story. One delegate I see describes it as a moment of patriotic drunkenness, people throwing their distinctions on the bonfire and saying, yeah, let's all pay tax. And the madness is this whole situation would not have come about if they had just agreed to pay tax as the king wanted a year or two earlier. The extent to which
从那时起，人们就不需要到处洗劫城堡和修道院了。他以一种非常随意的态度提出的另一件事是，王国里的每个人都应该纳税。这正是去年激励人们拒绝接受国王财政解决方案的问题。这是最疯狂的事情，不是吗？这是整个故事中最疯狂的方面。我看到一位代表将其描述为“爱国醉酒”的时刻，人们把他们的区别扔进篝火，说，是的，让我们都纳税。而疯狂之处在于，如果他们在一两年前就同意像国王想要的那样纳税，整个局面就不会发生。他们转变的程度，
they have swung and they're now seized with this almost hysterical, almost paranoid passion. I mean, it really is one of the great political turnarounds. Yeah. So Sharma calls it a cult of self-dispossession. And I mean, I think it is something that would be very recognisable today. It's people checking their privilege. Yeah. Standing up and saying, I have too much privilege. I must get rid of it all. But there's also, I mean, there's kind of tit for tat quality between the, say, the representatives of the church and the aristocracy. So a bishop proposes the abolition of all hunting rights. So essentially from this point on, anyone can just go and shoot anything that they want. And so Duke then stands up and says, yeah, fine, but we'll get rid of church
他们现在被这种近乎歇斯底里、近乎偏执的激情所控制。我的意思是，这确实是伟大的政治大转弯之一。是的。所以夏尔马称之为“自我剥夺的崇拜”。我的意思是，我认为这在今天是非常可识别的。这是人们在检查自己的特权。是的。站起来说，我有太多的特权。我必须摆脱这一切。但也有，我的意思是，在教会代表和贵族之间有一种“以牙还牙”的性质。所以一位主教提议废除所有狩猎权。所以本质上从这一点开始，任何人都可以去射杀他们想要的任何东西。于是公爵站起来说，是的，没问题，但我们要废除教会
tithes. And by the end of it, I think it's not just feudalism that's been jettisoned, but the very notion of privilege itself. And so William Doyle in the Oxford History of the French Revolution, he says it proved to be the most sweeping and radical legislative session of the whole French Revolution. And it was all just the event of an evening, a night, people standing up and saying, let's get rid of everything. And isn't it crazy that all that fuss about the defence of privilege and privilege being part of liberty, and now in one evening, they're throwing them all away. It's amazing. And then, of course, three weeks later comes the declaration, which is the second
什一税。到最后，我认为不仅封建主义被抛弃了，连特权本身的概念也被抛弃了。威廉·多伊尔在《法国大革命牛津史》中说，这被证明是整个法国大革命中最彻底、最激进的立法会议。而这一切只是一个晚上、一个夜晚的事件，人们站起来说，让我们摆脱一切。疯狂的是，所有关于捍卫特权以及特权是自由一部分的喧嚣，现在在一个晚上，他们就把它们全部扔掉了。这太神奇了。然后，当然，三周后出现了宣言，这是立法过程中
kind of monumental moment in this process of legislation. And you said last time that actually the guy who originally proposes it is your mate Lafayette. An empty-headed political dwarf, as the dictionary of the French Revolution calls him. Or a dashing representative of Franco-American friendship. Yeah. And obviously he's been in America. He's very close to George Washington, has close relations with Thomas Jefferson, who is the American ambassador in Paris at this point.
第二个纪念碑式的时刻。你上次说，实际上最初提出它的人是你的伙伴拉法耶特。一个“头脑空空的政治侏儒”，正如《法国大革命词典》所称的那样。或者是一个法美友谊的潇洒代表。是的。显然他去过美国。他与乔治·华盛顿非常亲近，与此时担任美国驻巴黎大使的托马斯·杰斐逊关系密切。
And so he basically proposes that it be on the American model. You know, just as the American Declaration had joined the various states in America together, he thinks that it will help unify a sundering nation in France. And it proclaims 17 rights. And the first of these, men are born and remain free and equal in rights. Social distinctions may be based only on considerations of the common good. So that is egalité. That's the expression of all the feudal privileges that have been jettisoned. And this in turn then defines what the purpose of good governance should be. So the aim of every political association is the
所以他基本上提议以美国模式为蓝本。你知道，就像美国宣言将美国各州联合在一起一样，他认为这将有助于统一法国这个正在分裂的国家。它宣布了17项权利。其中第一项是：人在权利上生来而且始终是自由平等的。社会区别只能基于共同利益的考虑。所以这就是“平等”。这是对所有被抛弃的封建特权的表达。而这反过来又定义了良好治理的目的应该是什么。所以每个政治协会的目的都是
preservation of the natural and imprescriptible rights of man. These rights are liberty, property, safety, and resistance to oppression. With an emphasis there, I think, on the first word, liberte. So that's the second article. And I think it's very obvious what the target of that article is. And the third article makes it clear. The principle of any sovereignty lies primarily in the nation. No corporate body, no individual may exercise any authority that does not expressly emanate from it. So the corporate body is clearly the church and the individual is clearly the king, although neither are actually mentioned. And no supernatural authority there either. So no God, right? But interestingly, the nation, so a new abstract noun, no one questions what the nation might be or says, well, actually, that's quite hard toed. So that's the more abstract end of the list.
保护人自然且不可剥夺的权利。这些权利是自由、财产、安全和反抗压迫。我认为重点在于第一个词，自由。所以这是第二条。我认为那一条的目标非常明显。第三条明确了这一点。任何主权原则主要在于国家。任何团体、任何个人不得行使未经明确授权的任何权力。所以团体显然是教会，个人显然是国王，尽管两者都没有被实际提及。那里也没有超自然权威。所以没有上帝，对吧？但有趣的是，“国家”，一个新的抽象名词，没有人质疑国家可能是什么，或者说，嗯，实际上这很难界定。所以这是清单中更抽象的一端。
But what you then have is a whole list of articles that are clearly very, very prescriptively trying to knock away the various props of the Ancien Régime. So Article 9, every man is presumed innocent until he's been declared guilty. That's targeting the lettres de cachet, the way in which the king could just have people arrested and put in prison article 10 no one may be disturbed on account of his opinions even religious ones as long as the manifestation of such opinions does not interfere with the established law and order so that's targeting the privileged position held by the catholic church and you know this is in law so ever since 1715 when the huguenots the protestants had been named illegal catholicism had been the only
但你随后拥有的是一整套条款，显然非常非常规范地试图敲掉旧制度的各种支柱。第九条，每个人在被宣告有罪之前都被推定为无罪。这针对的是“密札”，即国王可以随意逮捕人并把他们关进监狱的方式。第十条，任何人不得因其意见，即使是宗教意见，而受到干扰，只要这些意见的表达不干扰既定的法律和秩序。所以这针对的是天主教会所持有的特权地位，你知道，这是法律，所以自从1715年胡格诺派（新教徒）被宣布为非法以来，天主教一直是唯一
legally permissible faith. And so it's unsurprising that actually even the clerics who have cheerfully jettisoned their privileges are very, very upset about this. And it's their opposition that delays the final agreement on this document for about a week. And then article 11, the free communication of ideas and opinions is one of the most precious rights of man. So no more censorship, whether that's coming from the king or from the church. So Tom, the question is, I mean, some of these things as an Anglo-Saxon, you could say, you know, we have quite a lot of this in Britain or in the new United States of America. So to what extent do you think this is genuinely, I mean, I can see how you feel for a Frenchman. You think this is groundbreaking and a transformative moment in world history.
法律上允许的信仰。所以毫不奇怪，实际上即使是那些愉快地抛弃了特权的神职人员也对此感到非常非常不安。正是他们的反对推迟了这份文件的最终协议大约一周。然后第十一条，思想和意见的自由交流是人最宝贵的权利之一。所以不再有审查，无论是来自国王还是教会。所以汤姆，问题是，我的意思是，作为盎格鲁-撒克逊人，其中一些事情，你可以说，你知道，我们在英国或新的美利坚合众国有很多这样的东西。所以你认为这在多大程度上是真正地——我的意思是，我能看出你作为一个法国人是如何感受的。你认为这是开创性的，是世界历史上的一个变革时刻。
But of course, to go back to the Margaret Thatcher argument, could you say, well, a lot of this exists already, what's so special and what's so groundbreaking about all this? I think it is an absolutely decisive moment in world history. And it's decisive because it is an overt rupture with so much that had gone before. And it's a rupture that's happening in the preeminent intellectual capital of Europe. But I think it's also significant as a reiteration of things that had gone before. So I don't think that the rupture is quite as complete as people say. So it's very self-consciously a new beginning. This is the great kind of manifesting principle that governs the whole declaration. But of course, as you pointed out, the revolutionaries aren't the
但当然，回到玛格丽特·撒切尔的论点，你可以说，嗯，很多东西已经存在了，这一切有什么特别之处，有什么开创性的？我认为这是世界历史上一个绝对决定性的时刻。它是决定性的，因为它与之前发生的一切有着公开的决裂。而且这种决裂发生在欧洲最杰出的知识之都。但我认为它作为对之前事物的重申也具有重要意义。所以我认为这种决裂并不像人们说的那么彻底。所以它非常有意识地是一个新的开始。这是统治整个宣言的伟大原则。但当然，正如你指出的，革命者并不是
first to attempt such a thing. And it's kind of implicit in the declaration because it's saying that the rights it proclaims are unnatural, unalienable, and sacred. Then it's mad to think that they can't have been proclaimed before. Or are the French saying they're the first people to discover them? And then there's the further issue of, is this a document that is targeted at France at a particular moment in its history? Or are the pretensions it has to be universal, are they authentic? Well, that's la nation. If you're talking about the nation, that raises that as a problem, doesn't it? I mean, this is an argument that goes to the core of the French revolution. Is it universalist? Well, it obviously is universalist, but it is also the crucible of nationalism. And it's France that invents
第一个尝试这种事情的人。这在宣言中是隐含的，因为它说它所宣布的权利是自然的、不可剥夺的和神圣的。那么认为它们以前没有被宣布过是疯狂的。或者法国人是在说他们是第一个发现这些权利的人吗？然后还有一个进一步的问题：这是一份针对法国历史特定时刻的文件吗？还是它所具有的普世性主张是真实的？嗯，那就是“国家”。如果你在谈论国家，这会引发一个问题，不是吗？我的意思是，这是一个触及法国大革命核心的论点。它是普世主义的吗？嗯，它显然是普世主义的，但它也是民族主义的熔炉。是法国发明了
modern nationalism. Yeah. And so there's a massive tension there, which I think will run throughout the revolution and indeed throughout 19th and 20th century history as well. But what it does very effectively is to provide a kind of legal imprimatur for the destruction of the Ancien Régime. So it is the intellectual parallel to the demolition of the stones of the Bastille. So just as the walls of the Bastille are being demolished, the appearance of these words and articles on a piece of paper that then gets passed is doing something similar. It is eradicating, supposedly, the taint of absolutism. So this idea that sovereignty now lies with the nation and not the king, I mean, this is a massive,
现代民族主义。是的。所以那里有一种巨大的张力，我认为这将贯穿整个革命，实际上也贯穿整个19世纪和20世纪的历史。但它非常有效地提供了一种摧毁旧制度的法律印记。所以它是巴士底狱石头拆除的知识平行物。所以正如巴士底狱的墙壁正在被拆除，这些文字和条款出现在一张纸上并获得通过，也在做类似的事情。它正在消除，据称，绝对主义的污点。所以这种主权现在属于国家而不是国王的想法，我的意思是，这是一个巨大的、
massive step. And the implications for what had previously been the two estates, the nobility and the church, are obviously also seismic. So the logical implication is that the nobility should no longer exist. If they have no privileges, then what's the point of them? And basically within less than a year, so on the 19th of June, 1790, all hereditary titles are abolished and all the kind of traditional symbols of nobility. So coats of arms, the kind of deliveries that are worn by servants, people with their own pews in church, all that kind of thing, they all go. But it's the church, I liveries that are worn by servants, people with their own pews in church, all that kind of thing. They all go. But it's the church, I think, that actually loses even more because
巨大的步骤。对之前两个等级——贵族和教会——的影响显然也是震撼性的。所以逻辑上的含义是贵族不应该再存在。如果他们没有特权，那么他们存在的意义是什么？基本上在不到一年内，即1790年6月19日，所有世袭头衔都被废除了，所有传统的贵族象征也是如此。所以纹章、仆人穿的制服、在教堂里有自己长椅的人，所有这些东西，它们都消失了。但教会，我
most of the aristocracy have so much land. And of course, property has been guaranteed under the Declaration of the Rights of Man. So they keep their lands. For the church, it's a much more crippling fact that tithes have been abolished. So tithes, you know, the money that is raised to keep the church going, that's gone. So when that happens, particularly the poor parish clergy have completely lost their source of income. And the Catholic Church has also been forced to conceive complete and total freedom of worship and thought. And I think that in a way, in the context of France, this is the most
认为实际上损失更大，因为大多数贵族拥有很多土地。当然，财产在《人权宣言》下得到了保障。所以他们保留了他们的土地。对于教会来说，什一税被废除是一个更具破坏性的事实。所以什一税，你知道，为维持教会运作而筹集的钱，没了。所以当这种情况发生时，特别是贫穷的教区神职人员完全失去了他们的收入来源。天主教会也被迫构想出完全和彻底的礼拜和思想自由。我认为在某种程度上，在法国的背景下，这是最
revolutionary development of all because the church in France is an even older institution than the monarchy. Its privileges have been writ very, very large over the course of French history, going back to the very founding of the monarchy. So I think two scenes from the reign of Louis XVI kind of illustrate the way in which even the monarchy stands in the shadow of the monarchy. So I think two scenes from the reign of Louis XVI kind of illustrate the way in which even the monarchy stands in the shadow of the antiquity of the church. So Louis' coronation in June 1775, massively retro, even though actually Louis does make sure that Marie Antoinette has her own purpose-built toilet, which was very nice of him. So it's held in Rass, the traditional place for kings to be crowned. This is the key episode in The Life of Joan of Arc, where she gets to crown the Dauphin there.
革命性的发展，因为法国的教会是一个比君主制更古老的机构。它的特权在法国历史进程中被写得非常非常大，可以追溯到君主制的建立。所以我认为路易十六统治时期的两个场景说明了即使是君主制也站在教会古老性的阴影下。所以路易在1775年6月的加冕礼，非常复古，尽管实际上路易确实确保了玛丽·安托瓦内特有她自己专门建造的厕所，这对他来说非常不错。所以它在兰斯举行，这是国王加冕的传统地点。这是《圣女贞德传》中的关键一集，她在那里为王储加冕。
But the reason why Reims is the place that you go is that in 496, the first Frankish king to convert to Christianity had been crowned there. And he had supposedly been anointed with oil from a kind of a flask, a casket that had been brought down by a white dove. And Louis standing there being anointed, being crowned, this is his oath. I swear to devote myself sincerely and with all my power to annihilating heretics condemned by the church in all lands under my rule. So there you have everything that the enlightened despise of the French church, kind of doves coming down with oil and sectarian
但兰斯之所以是你去的地方，是因为在496年，第一个皈依基督教的法兰克国王在那里加冕。他据称被一种油膏抹，这种油来自一个由白鸽带来的瓶子、一个匣子。路易站在那里被涂油、被加冕，这是他的誓言：“我发誓真诚地并尽我所能致力于消灭教会谴责的异端，在我的统治下的所有土地上。”所以那里有启蒙运动者所鄙视的法国教会的一切，鸽子带着油降临，以及对新教徒的宗派
hostility to Protestants. An oath that Louis would undoubtedly have taken enormously seriously. And as we'll see, the fact that he is now contravening that oath and what he sees as his loyalty to the church more generally, that is going to have a massive psychological impact on him. It will. And then Dominic bookending that at the beginning of his reign, the episode that you described in the previous episode where he comes to Paris after the fall of the Bastille and he goes to the Hotel de Ville and he is given the cockade. Oh yeah, by Lafayette. Yeah, by Lafayette. And this will form the colors of the tricolour. So white for the color of the monarchy and blue and red for the city of Paris. And why red and blue? These are the colors of the two saints, two of the patron saints of Paris. So the blue is for Saint
敌意。路易无疑会非常认真地对待这个誓言。正如我们将看到的，他现在违反了那个誓言，以及他更广泛地认为自己对教会的忠诚，这将对他产生巨大的心理影响。会的。然后多米尼克，在他统治初期，你在上一集中描述的那一集，他在巴士底狱陷落后来到巴黎，他去了市政厅，他被授予了帽徽。哦，是的，拉法耶特给的。是的，拉法耶特。这将形成三色旗的颜色。所以白色代表君主制的颜色，蓝色和红色代表巴黎市。为什么是红色和蓝色？这是两个圣人的颜色，巴黎的两个守护圣人之一。所以蓝色代表圣
Martin, Saint Martin of Tours, a man of very humble stock who in the fourth century had risen to become the Bishop of Tours. And he is famous, of course, for giving half his cloak to a beggar who had no clothes, who you might describe as a sans-culotte, a man too poor to buy his own clothes. And Saint-Martin gives him the cloak to cover him. And the red is for Saint-Denis. And Saint-Denis had supposedly been beheaded in the third century on a great hill overlooking Paris that had then been given the name of Montmartre, the mountain of the martyr. And from Montmartre, Saint-Denis was
马丁，图尔的圣马丁，一个出身非常卑微的人，在四世纪崛起成为图尔的主教。他当然以把一半斗篷给了一个没有衣服的乞丐而闻名，你可以称他为“无套裤汉”，一个穷得买不起自己衣服的人。圣马丁把斗篷给了他来遮盖他。红色代表圣丹尼斯。圣丹尼斯据称在三世纪在俯瞰巴黎的一座大山上被斩首，那座山后来被命名为蒙马特，即“殉道者之山”。从蒙马特，圣丹尼斯
supposed to have carried his head, preaching a sermon as he went. He then reaches a spot to the north of Paris where he finally dies and a great basilica dedicated to Saint-Denis is raised over it. And this is the French Westminster Abbey. This is where all the kings and queens of France are buried. And it kind of beautifully exemplifies the historical ironies and tensions of the fact that this cockade that Louis is wearing in his hat, it's a symbol of a new order. It's the union of a patriot king, a constitutional king with his people. But it also, without most people even thinking about it, has these echoes of a fabulously ancient past. And it focuses, I think, the big question, is it possible actually to have a new beginning that doesn't bear these trace elements of the past? Right. Can you have year
据称带着他的头，边走边讲道。他随后到达巴黎北部的一个地点，在那里他最终去世，一座献给圣丹尼斯的宏伟教堂建在上面。这是法国的威斯敏斯特教堂。这是所有法国国王和王后埋葬的地方。它非常优美地体现了历史的讽刺和张力，路易戴在帽子上的这个帽徽，它是新秩序的象征。它是爱国国王、立宪国王与他的人民的结合。但它也，在大多数人甚至没有想到的情况下，有着这种极其古老的过去的呼应。我认为它聚焦了一个大问题：是否真的有可能拥有一个不带有这些过去痕迹的新开始？对吧。你能有年份吗
zero? Or are you inevitably, in doing that, going to bear the kind of the marks of the contamination of the past, reaching back, you know, not just decades, but centuries and even millennia. And you can ask the same question about the Declaration of the Rights of Man and the Citizen. Is it a repudiation of the Catholic heritage, the Christian heritage? Or Dominic, is it something more complex? Is it a reworking of it? So when people ask, is it a bit more complex? They never say no, it's actually much simpler. Have you noticed that?
零？还是说你在做这件事的时候，不可避免地会带有过去污染的痕迹，不仅追溯到几十年前，甚至几百年前，乃至几千年前。你也可以对《人权和公民权宣言》提出同样的问题。它是对天主教遗产、基督教遗产的否定吗？还是说，多米尼克，它更复杂一些？它是对这些遗产的重构吗？所以当人们问，它是不是更复杂一点？他们从不回答“不，其实简单得多”。你注意到了吗？
They never do that, Tom. I've never known you do that in 500 episodes. Because it never is, is it? Right. We will take a break and then we'll come back to find out inevitably how it is more complex. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
他们从不那样做，汤姆。在500期节目里，我从没见过你那样做。因为它从来都不简单，不是吗？没错。我们要休息一下，回来后再去探究它究竟是如何变得更复杂的。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Inspired by the American Declaration of Independence in 1776 and the spirit of the Enlightenment, the Declaration of the Rights of Man and of the Citizen of 1789 marked the beginning of a new political era. So that's the introduction to the Declaration of the Rights of Man and the Citizen on the Elysee Palace website. Tom, shocking they don't mention the Glorious Revolution.
这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告内容、额外剧集并提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。受1776年美国《独立宣言》和启蒙运动精神的启发，1789年的《人权和公民权宣言》标志着一个新政治时代的开始。这就是爱丽舍宫网站上对《人权和公民权宣言》的介绍。汤姆，令人震惊的是他们竟然没提到光荣革命。
Magna Carta. Astonishing, isn't it? How could they have overlooked that? And Britain's own wonderful traditions of liberty and freedom. Very weird. I mean, I'm sure American listeners would be thrilled to know that the French acknowledged that the American Revolution played some part as an inspiration. And of course,
大宪章。太令人惊讶了，不是吗？他们怎么会忽略那个呢？还有英国自身美妙的自由传统。太奇怪了。我的意思是，我相信美国听众会很高兴知道法国人承认美国革命作为一种灵感发挥了作用。当然，
the guy who's the link is Lafayette, who we mentioned. And we mentioned also that when he's drawing it up, he's assisted by Thomas Jefferson, who is in situ in Paris as the American ambassador. But I think, and American listeners may want to cover, there is at this point, I think what is striking about it is that the French declaration is much, much more ambitious than the American one. You don't get a list of rights in the American declaration of independence. And the French declaration, as we've noted, is much, much more kind of soaringly universalist. It claims to speak on behalf, not just of the French, but of all mankind. The American one is just a lot of whining, really, about fake accusations against George III, isn't it?
那个关键人物是拉法耶特，我们提到过他。我们还提到，当他起草这份宣言时，得到了托马斯·杰斐逊的协助，当时杰斐逊正以美国大使的身份驻扎在巴黎。但我认为，美国听众可能想捂住耳朵，此时此刻，我认为引人注目的是，法国的宣言比美国的要宏大得多。你在美国《独立宣言》中找不到权利清单。而法国的宣言，正如我们所指出的，在某种程度上更加高远且具有普世性。它声称不仅代表法国人，而且代表全人类发言。美国的宣言其实更多是在抱怨针对乔治三世的虚假指控，不是吗？
Right. In contrast to the French Declaration of Rights, which Jonathan Israel sums up, the rights the French adopted for themselves were proclaimed universal rights, belonging equally to all of whatever nation, station, faith, or ethnicity. So you could see that either as soaringly idealistic or as hilariously arrogant. Yeah, or maybe both. Yes. So let's zero in on this enlightenment issue and Jonathan Israel's argument. So Jonathan Israel argues that the enlightenment is driven by human reason and scientific inquiry and all
没错。与法国的《人权宣言》形成对比的是，乔纳森·以色列总结道，法国人为自己采纳的权利被宣布为普世权利，平等地属于任何国家、地位、信仰或种族的所有人。所以你可以将其视为高远的理想主义，或者滑稽的傲慢。是的，或者两者兼而有之。是的。那么让我们聚焦于这个启蒙运动的问题和乔纳森·以色列的论点。乔纳森·以色列认为，启蒙运动是由人类理性和科学探究所驱动的，以及所有
of that kind of thing, the skepticism, and that it has different phases. And there's something that he calls the radical enlightenment. How does he distinguish the radical enlightenment? So the radical enlightenment is overtly hostile to religion, often overtly hostile to monarchy. And because the French Revolution will end up bringing down both, it's understandable why people should look to the kind of the underground writings of the enlightenment for inspiration. And there are indisputably figures who do bear the markers of the underground writings of the Enlightenment for inspiration. And there are indisputably figures who do bear the markers of that. And probably the most famous of them is an aristocrat, inevitably, called the Marquis de Condorcet, who is a philosopher. He's a mathematician.
这类事物，即怀疑论，并且它有不同的阶段。他称之为“激进启蒙”。他是如何区分激进启蒙的？激进启蒙公开敌视宗教，通常也公开敌视君主制。由于法国大革命最终推翻了这两者，人们从启蒙运动的地下著作中寻找灵感是可以理解的。毫无疑问，确实有一些人物带有启蒙运动地下著作的印记。毫无疑问，确实有一些人物带有这些印记。其中最著名的大概是一位贵族，不可避免地，他叫孔多塞侯爵，他是一位哲学家。他是一位数学家。
He's an economist. And a bit like Lavoisier, who we talked about in the previous episode, he's a great enthusiast for cleaning up rivers. It's a kind of Fergal Sharkey-esque quality. Our overseas listeners won't know who that is, Tom. So Fergal Sharkey is a campaigner against pollution in Britain's rivers. And he and the Marquis de Conce would have gone on tremendously well. And his hostility to sewage in rivers is reflective of his hostility to the sewage of superstition and barbarism in public discourse, Dominic. Right. No one likes the sewage of barbarism, do they?
他是一位经济学家。就像我们在上一集谈到的拉瓦锡一样，他非常热衷于清理河流。这有一种弗格·沙基式的特质。我们的海外听众不知道那是谁，汤姆。弗格·沙基是一位反对英国河流污染的活动家。他和孔多塞侯爵会相处得非常好。他对河流中污水的厌恶，反映了他对公共话语中迷信和野蛮污水的厌恶，多米尼克。没错。没人喜欢野蛮的污水，对吧？
Well, I don't know. I've got a slight soft spot for it, I'll be honest. And so unsurprisingly, when the revolution kicks off, the Marquis de Condorcet is a huge enthusiast for it. And he casts it absolutely as it so often is to this day as being the triumph of progress over superstition. And he's very, very into the idea that what you have to do is dig down deep, muster empirical data, don't rely on kind of mad stories about doves bringing down holy oil or anything like that. You know, that's not going to help in the battle with ignorance and poverty. Christianity is nonsense. It's objective reason that will provide the inspiration for people in the war against
嗯，我不知道。老实说，我对此有一点点偏爱。所以不出所料，当革命爆发时，孔多塞侯爵是它的狂热支持者。他将其完全描述为——直到今天依然如此——进步战胜迷信的胜利。他非常热衷于这样一种观点：你必须深入挖掘，收集经验数据，不要依赖那些关于鸽子带来圣油之类的疯狂故事。你知道，那对对抗无知和贫困毫无帮助。基督教是无稽之谈。是客观理性将为人们对抗
all the faults that the Ancien Régime had embodied. And he sees the duty of the revolution to scour France and indeed more broadly the world free of the taint of specifically Christianity, which he detests. So he says, the Christian millennium is an impressive demonstration of what energetic reactionaries can do to spread superstition, demote the intellect, prolong stagnation, secure tyranny, degrade man as a reasonable being, and thus hold back the march of mind for centuries. And in saying that, he is echoing the kind of underground Enlightenment philosophers, but he is also echoing the most famous of all the French philosophers of the 18th century, who we've
旧制度所体现的所有弊病提供灵感。他认为革命的职责是扫除法国乃至更广泛世界中基督教的污点，他对此深恶痛绝。所以他说，基督教千年史是一个令人印象深刻的证明，展示了精力充沛的反动派如何传播迷信、降低智力、延长停滞、巩固暴政、贬低作为理性存在的人，从而阻碍了思想的进步长达数个世纪。在这样说的时候，他不仅是在呼应那些地下启蒙哲学家，也是在呼应18世纪最著名的法国哲学家，我们已经
already mentioned, who's Voltaire. The great wit who had cast the Bastille as this terrible dungeon he'd written up about the man in the iron mask. And he's very, very, I mean, he's probably the most famous writer in 18th century Europe. He's dead by the time the revolution breaks out. But he's a massive, massive influence on the way that Europe and France particularly has come to see the past. And Voltaire's great clarion cry is, Écrase l'infame, destroy the infamous thing, the thing of infamy, by which he doesn't just mean the Catholic church, although the Catholic church is the
提到过他，那就是伏尔泰。这位伟大的智者曾将巴士底狱描述为可怕的地牢，他还写过关于铁面人的文章。他非常、非常——我的意思是，他可能是18世纪欧洲最著名的作家。革命爆发时他已经去世了。但他对欧洲，特别是法国看待过去的方式产生了巨大的影响。伏尔泰伟大的号角是“粉碎卑劣之物”（Écrase l'infame），摧毁那个卑劣的东西，那个耻辱之物。他指的不仅仅是天主教会，尽管天主教会是他
particular object of his hatred. He basically means Christianity. And so he was explicit about this. Every sensible man, every honorable man must hold the Christian sect in horror. And he is a brilliant, brilliant writer, but he's also a brilliant activist. And again and again, he fixes on examples of tyranny and oppression that he knows will resonate with the French people. So his story about the man in the iron mask is one of those, but there's an even more vivid example because it happens in his own lifetime. So he's picking up on a live injustice. And this happened in 1762, and it was a Protestant, a Huguenot from Toulouse in the south of France called Jean Calin,
仇恨的特定对象。他基本上指的是基督教。所以他对此表达得很明确。每一个明智的人，每一个光荣的人，都必须对基督教派感到恐惧。他是一位才华横溢的作家，但也是一位杰出的活动家。他一次又一次地聚焦于他知道会引起法国人民共鸣的暴政和压迫的例子。所以他关于铁面人的故事就是其中之一，但有一个更生动的例子，因为它发生在他自己的有生之年。所以他是在处理一个当下的不公正事件。这发生在1762年，当时图卢兹的一位新教徒，胡格诺派教徒，名叫让·卡拉斯，
who had been accused of murdering his own son. And he had been convicted under very dubious circumstances. Yeah, he obviously didn't kill him. So it turns out, and he's broken very horribly on the wheel. And Voltaire picks up on this and he says he was broken on the wheel, not because people really thought that he killed his son, but because he was a Protestant. It's an example of religious intolerance at its brutal worst. He casts Calin as a victim of sectarian persecution. And his campaign has such an impact that in 1764, so only two years after he had died, Louis XV, the predecessor of Louis XVI, had actually received Calas' family at Versailles and the following year had issued a posthumous exoneration, a pardon.
被指控谋杀了自己的儿子。他在非常可疑的情况下被定罪。是的，他显然没有杀他。结果证明，他在刑轮上受尽了可怕的折磨。伏尔泰注意到了这一点，他说他在刑轮上受刑，不是因为人们真的认为他杀了儿子，而是因为他是新教徒。这是宗教不宽容的最残酷例证。他将卡拉斯塑造成宗派迫害的受害者。他的运动产生了如此大的影响，以至于在1764年，也就是他死后仅两年，路易十六的前任路易十五，竟然在凡尔赛宫接见了卡拉斯的家人，并在次年发布了死后平反的赦免令。
And this is typical of Voltaire's campaigning. And it makes him someone that people not just in kind of the radical wing of French opinion, but across the whole span of French society comes to admire very much. So in 1778, Talleyrand, the Bishop of Autun, had actually gone and visited Voltaire. So Voltaire had been in exile in Geneva. He'd come to Paris and Talleyrand had gone to visit Voltaire there. And Voltaire by this point is incredibly old. He has this gone to visit Voltaire there. And Voltaire, by this point, is incredibly old. He has this brilliant description of Voltaire. Every line of that remarkable countenance is engraved in my memory. I see it now before me, the small fiery eyes staring from shrunken sockets,
这就是伏尔泰竞选活动的典型特征。这使他不仅在法国舆论的激进派中，而且在整个法国社会中都受到人们的极大钦佩。所以1778年，欧坦主教塔列朗竟然去拜访了伏尔泰。当时伏尔泰在日内瓦流亡。他来到巴黎，塔列朗去那里拜访了他。伏尔泰此时已经非常老了。他有这种去拜访他。伏尔泰此时已经非常老了。他有这种对伏尔泰的精彩描述。那张非凡面孔上的每一道皱纹都铭刻在我的记忆中。我现在还能看到它，那双从深陷的眼窝中凝视的小而炽热的眼睛，
not unlike those of a chameleon. And it's widely held by enthusiasts for the revolution, that he is the father of it. The glorious revolution has been the fruit of his works, one of them says. And in fact, in 1791, so two years after the fall of the Bastille, Voltaire's remains are dug up and reinterred in what is an almost completed church, but has been re-consecrated as a temple to liberty, the Pantheon, the temple to all the gods. And Voltaire is buried there amidst kind of great splendor as one of the kind of the presiding inspirations for the revolution. But obviously, so you can see why all this stuff, the Declaration of the Rights of Man, the legacy of Voltaire would appeal to the Marquis de Condorcet or somebody who sees himself as an enlightened free thinker. I mean, genuinely a kind of metropolitan intellectual.
就像变色龙的眼睛一样。革命的狂热支持者普遍认为他是革命之父。其中一人说，光荣的革命是他作品的果实。事实上，在1791年，也就是巴士底狱陷落两年后，伏尔泰的遗骸被挖掘出来，重新安葬在一个几乎完工的教堂里，但该教堂已被重新祝圣为自由之神庙——先贤祠，即众神之神庙。伏尔泰被安葬在那里，场面极其壮观，作为革命的指导灵感之一。但显然，你可以看出为什么所有这些东西，如《人权宣言》、伏尔泰的遗产，会吸引孔多塞侯爵或任何自视为开明自由思想家的人。我的意思是，他确实是一个大都市知识分子。
But obviously, most of France is not populated by people like that. It's a very rural country where millions upon millions of people work the land. They're used to the old ways, the old parish church, the local curé, the rituals of the Catholic year, all of that kind of stuff. And they are not reading Voltaire. So what on earth did they make of this move from August 1789 onwards, the kind of anti-Christian side of the revolution? I think lots of them come to be enthused by the spirit of the revolution. I think they come to accept the revolution on its own terms, but equally lots of them are appalled. And the more devout among Catholics come to see the whole revolution basically as a
但显然，法国的大多数人并不是那样的人。这是一个非常乡村的国家，数以百万计的人在土地上劳作。他们习惯了旧的方式，旧的教区教堂，当地的本堂神父，天主教年度的仪式，所有这些东西。他们不读伏尔泰。那么，从1789年8月开始，他们对革命中这种反基督教的一面到底作何感想呢？我认为他们中许多人开始被革命精神所鼓舞。我认为他们开始按照革命自己的条件接受革命，但同样，他们中许多人感到震惊。虔诚的天主教徒开始将整个革命基本上视为
massive Protestant plot. And one of the reasons for that is that Protestants are actually, they have quite leading roles in the revolution. The moment that they're allowed to kind of practice their religion freely, they're busy building churches. They're often quite wealthy, so they have the money to hand. They're busy joining revolutionary committees in Paris and across the whole of France. And in March, 1790, a Protestant pastor is actually elected president of the National Assembly. So Catholics who feel upset about what is happening, they look at this and you can find evidence for thinking, well, it's Protestants who are behind it. And I think what kind of really puts rocket fuel in that fear is the fact that there are
一个巨大的新教阴谋。原因之一是新教徒实际上在革命中扮演了相当主导的角色。一旦他们被允许自由地实践他们的宗教，他们就忙着建造教堂。他们通常相当富有，所以手头有钱。他们忙着加入巴黎和整个法国的革命委员会。1790年3月，一位新教牧师甚至当选为国民议会主席。所以，对正在发生的事情感到不安的天主教徒看着这一切，你可以找到证据认为，嗯，是新教徒在背后操纵。我认为真正给这种恐惧火上浇油的是，有
clearly two massive echoes of the Reformation that Catholics find quite hard to miss. So the attack on the Catholic church again and again is cast as an attack on superstition. Very Thomas Cromwell. Yes. So the attacks on privilege are often very stridently anti-clerical. And just as in the Reformation, so now the end of censorship means that pamphlets and illustrations can flood everywhere. And you don't even need to be able to read to understand kind of anti-clerical, anti-religious pamphlets. It's immediately apparent. And anyone with any familiarity with the Reformation would, of course, immediately see the parallels. And just as Luther had kind of staged mocking ceremonies that symbolically cast contempt
两个明显的宗教改革回声，天主教徒很难忽略。因此，对天主教会的攻击一次又一次地被描述为对迷信的攻击。非常像托马斯·克伦威尔。是的。所以对特权的攻击通常是非常尖锐的反教权主义。正如在宗教改革时期一样，现在审查制度的终结意味着小册子和插图可以到处泛滥。你甚至不需要识字就能理解那种反教权、反宗教的小册子。这是显而易见的。任何熟悉宗教改革的人，当然会立即看到其中的相似之处。正如路德曾上演过嘲弄仪式，象征性地表达对
on the papacy, the same thing is happening in the revolution. The church and the aristocracy are both objects of kind of staged managed processions that make them out to be kind of completely ridiculous. You get parodies of the mass, plays that are very anti-clerical get put on in the Paris theatres sponsored by enthusiasts for the revolution. And undoubtedly, lots of people are swayed by this. They find it very exciting, the way in which suddenly they're being allowed to think in ways that they previously had never thought to think. But there are others who find it unsettling. So that's on the ideological level. But of course, the Reformation isn't just about ideology.
教皇制度的蔑视，同样的事情也在革命中发生。教会和贵族都是那种精心策划的游行示威的对象，这些游行将他们描绘得完全荒谬可笑。你会有弥撒的模仿，由革命狂热分子赞助的巴黎剧院上演非常反教权主义的戏剧。毫无疑问，许多人被此所左右。他们觉得这非常令人兴奋，他们突然被允许以以前从未想过的方式去思考。但也有其他人觉得这令人不安。所以这是在意识形态层面。但当然，宗教改革不仅仅是关于意识形态。
About money. It's also about hard cash and property. Yeah. And there is an attack that kind of builds up from the abolition of the church's tithes through the months and years that follow that is actually pretty Henry VIII. Because we've said the revolution hasn't really improved the fiscal crisis that had done so much to bring it about. France is still basically bankrupt. There's no money. So how to plug the gap? And that's exactly the question that prompted Henry VIII to end up dissolving the monasteries. And it's the solution that the more radical elements in the National Assembly kind of start thinking, well, maybe we could do this. Yeah, because the church controls
关于金钱。它也关乎真金白银和财产。是的。从废除教会什一税开始，在随后的几个月和几年里，这种攻击实际上非常像亨利八世。因为我们说过，革命并没有真正改善导致其发生的财政危机。法国基本上仍然破产。没有钱。那么如何填补这个缺口呢？这正是促使亨利八世最终解散修道院的问题。这也是国民议会中更激进的分子开始思考的解决方案，嗯，也许我们可以这样做。是的，因为教会控制着
so much. Yeah. I mean, they own something like 10% of the nation's wealth. And who's the guy who basically proposes this? Talleyrand. It's Talleyrand. The Bishop of Houton. But I mean, that bishopric is kind of slightly nominal, isn't it? Let's be honest. Slightly. So he does this on the 10th of October. So that's a few months after the abolition of tithes. And I think actually, to be fair to Talleyrand, it's not just the kind of cynical proposal because he's saying, you know, we can take all this land and lots of the money can go towards helping the nation's finances, but we could also basically nationalize the church and we could use the money from all these properties to give all the people in the church a kind of flat fee, a flat income.
这么多。是的。我的意思是，他们拥有大约10%的国家财富。是谁基本上提出了这个建议？塔列朗。是塔列朗。欧坦的主教。但我的意思是，那个主教职位有点名义上的，不是吗？老实说。有点。所以他在10月10日做了这件事。也就是废除什一税几个月后。我认为实际上，公平地说，塔列朗，这不仅仅是一个愤世嫉俗的提议，因为他说，你知道，我们可以拿走所有这些土地，很多钱可以用来帮助国家的财政，但我们也可以基本上将教会国有化，我们可以利用所有这些财产的钱给教会里的所有人提供一种固定费用，一种固定收入。
And this isn't, Joseph II, the Habsburg emperor, the brother of Marie Antoinette, had come up with a very similar kind of wheeze and that basically had gone through. So, you know, there are elements within the church who think, yeah, fine, fair enough. And obviously the radical elements, say Mirabeau and all his pals, they think it's a brilliant idea and they take it to the National Assembly. The vast majority of people in the National Assembly aren't clergy, so they think it's brilliant as well. And the proposal is voted through. But it has to be said that for obvious reasons, most of the clergy really, really hate it. Because the implication is that they will now be kind of moral functionaries, state employees.
这并不是，约瑟夫二世，哈布斯堡皇帝，玛丽·安托瓦内特的兄弟，曾提出过一个非常类似的诡计，而且基本上已经通过了。所以，你知道，教会内部有一些人认为，是的，很好，很公平。显然，激进分子，比如米拉波和他的所有伙伴，他们认为这是一个绝妙的主意，并将其带到了国民议会。国民议会中的绝大多数人不是神职人员，所以他们也认为这很棒。该提案投票通过了。但必须说，出于显而易见的原因，大多数神职人员真的非常讨厌它。因为这意味着他们现在将成为某种道德职能人员，国家雇员。
And this isn't the sense they have of their own vocation at all. And isn't this interesting that when we were talking about the Estates General, which becomes the National Assembly, we were saying that some of the big drivers of reform are the parish priests who are the poorest people there, who are the closest to ordinary Frenchmen, who are often seized with a real idealism. Because they're the first to join the Estates General, aren't they? It's a few poor parish priests. Yeah, they're to go and join the Third Estate and become the National Assembly. But within months, a wedge is being driven between the revolution and probably the majority of ordinary priests.
这根本不是他们对自己职业的理解。当我们谈论三级会议（后来成为国民议会）时，我们说改革的一些主要推动者是教区神父，他们是那里最穷的人，最接近普通法国人，他们通常怀有真正的理想主义，这难道不有趣吗？因为他们是第一批加入三级会议的人，不是吗？是几个贫穷的教区神父。是的，他们去加入第三等级并成为国民议会。但在几个月内，革命与可能占多数的普通神父之间就产生了一条鸿沟。
Even those who end up signing up to it are very, very conflicted about it. I think the poorest priests are the ones likeliest to side with this because they stand to benefit. But obviously, any priest with a relatively higher income is going to have to take a pay cut. And the people who are really in the crosshairs are the monks and the nuns, just as they were in Henry VIII's reformation. Because first they've been deprived of their income, and now they're deprived of their lands. And the corollary of this is exactly as in Henry VIII's time. So on the 13th of February, all monasteries and convents, except those who are devoted to charitable work, are officially dissolved and it's forbidden people to start taking monastic vows. And how much is there in France the same prejudice, the same preconception that
即使是那些最终签署它的人，对此也非常、非常矛盾。我认为最贫穷的神父最有可能站在这一边，因为他们会受益。但显然，任何收入相对较高的神父都将不得不减薪。而真正处于风口浪尖的是僧侣和修女，就像他们在亨利八世的宗教改革中一样。因为首先他们被剥夺了收入，现在他们被剥夺了土地。其必然结果正如亨利八世时代一样。因此，在2月13日，所有修道院和女修道院，除了那些致力于慈善工作的，都被正式解散，并且禁止人们开始发修道誓言。法国在多大程度上存在同样的偏见，同样的先入之见，即
monks and nuns are incredibly fat and corrupt and sexually depraved? That classic kind of Protestant image. I think much greater, because I don't think that was the case in Reformation England, but it's definitely the case in 18th century France, that monks and nuns have been absolute staples of these kind of pornographic tracts that we've been talking about quite a lot, not because we're prurient, but because they condition how people see the establishment in quite a fundamental way. And there is a feeling among enthusiasts for the Enlightenment that they are useless. They contribute nothing to society.
僧侣和修女非常肥胖、腐败且性堕落？那种经典的新教形象。我认为程度要大得多，因为我不认为在宗教改革时期的英国是这样，但在18世纪的法国，僧侣和修女绝对是这些色情小册子的主要内容，我们一直在谈论这些，不是因为我们好色，而是因为它们在相当根本的层面上决定了人们如何看待建制派。启蒙运动的狂热支持者有一种感觉，认为他们是无用的。他们对社会毫无贡献。
Yeah. They need to be turned into useful citizens. And so March and April 1790, you get all these kind of bands of patriots with their placades and their revolutionary sashes turning up and going full Thomas Cromwell, kind of chucking the monks and the nuns out. So you can see why by the summer of 1790, I think that there is a kind of increasing sense of alienation in the church from the revolution. This is not what the Abbé de Sierre thought that he was encouraging when he first proposed dissolving the three estates into a single National Assembly. And in Talleyrand's own sea of Autun, you start getting letters from his flock kind of saying,
是的。他们需要被变成有用的公民。所以1790年3月和4月，你看到所有这些带着标语牌和革命腰带的爱国者队伍出现，完全变成了托马斯·克伦威尔，把僧侣和修女赶走。所以你可以看出为什么到1790年夏天，我认为教会对革命的疏离感在增加。这并不是西耶斯神父最初提议将三个等级合并为一个国民议会时所设想的。在塔列朗自己的欧坦教区，你开始收到来自他的羊群的信，说，
he's an absolute traitor. He's a Judas. What is he up to? But it's not just in Autun, it's across the whole of France. You get priests who, they don't want to dissolve their sense of themselves as belonging to God's church and to just become the equivalent of magistrates or officers in the army. Yeah, civil servants. The whole point of being a priest is that their primary loyalty is not to the patria, not to the nation. Yeah. It is to God. Well, there you have that tension, the universalism and the nationalism, yet again. But talking of universalism, you know, Catholicos means universal and the head of the universal
他是个彻头彻尾的叛徒。他是个犹大。他在搞什么鬼？但这不仅仅是在欧坦，而是在整个法国。你会有神父，他们不想解散他们作为上帝教会一员的自我意识，也不想仅仅成为地方法官或军队军官的等价物。是的，公务员。做神父的全部意义在于，他们的首要忠诚不是对祖国，不是对国家。是的。而是对上帝。好吧，你又一次看到了那种张力，普世主义和民族主义。但说到普世主义，你知道，天主教（Catholicos）意味着普世，而普世
church is the Pope. So that is the head of the church, not the National Assembly. And the Pope is saying, basically, I'm not going to put up with this, this kind of revolutionary stuff. So in secret, the Pope in Rome, Pius VI, he starts to condemn the Declaration of the Rights of Man and all the policies that are being pursued in France on relations to the church. And this obviously sets up a kind of massive tension within the church and by extension within the vast mass of the French people, not least because the National Assembly, rather than trying to arrive at an accommodation with the papacy and with the church, just doubles down. They're not in a mood to negotiate with superstition and absolutism. They're not going to allow privilege to flourish. And so they feel we need to find a supply of committed citizen priests.
教会的领袖是教皇。所以那是教会的领袖，而不是国民议会。教皇基本上说，我不会容忍这种革命的东西。因此，在罗马，教皇庇护六世秘密地开始谴责《人权宣言》以及法国在教会关系上所追求的所有政策。这显然在教会内部，进而延伸到广大法国人民中，造成了一种巨大的紧张关系，尤其是因为国民议会不仅没有试图与教皇和教会达成妥协，反而变本加厉。他们没有心情与迷信和专制谈判。他们不会允许特权繁荣。所以他们觉得我们需要找到一批坚定的公民神父。
The church as it stands is not doing that. So we need to push things forward. And their solution in July 1790 is to draw up what they call the civil constitution of the clergy. And by the tenets of this, priests and bishops are to be elected. And of course, the electorate by this point would include Protestants. It would include Jews. It would include self-professed atheists. And once they have been elected, everyone who is going to take up his position as a kind of state priest, citizen priest, will be obliged to swear an oath of loyalty to the nation and to its laws. And I think that to most people in the National Assembly, this doesn't seem a big deal at all.
现有的教会并没有这样做。所以我们需要推动事情向前发展。他们在1790年7月的解决方案是起草他们所谓的《教士公民组织法》。根据该法的原则，神父和主教将由选举产生。当然，到那时，选民将包括新教徒。它将包括犹太人。它将包括自称无神论者的人。一旦他们当选，每一个将要担任某种国家神父、公民神父职位的人，都将被要求宣誓效忠国家及其法律。我认为对于国民议会中的大多数人来说，这根本不算什么大事。
You know, it's a process of legislative tidying up. But to lots of priests, it's a source of complete agony because they have now been put in the position that lots of them have been struggling to avoid, where they have to choose between swearing this oath, the oath to the revolution, or staying true to the authority of the Pope, of the Church, of God. It's a massive moment, isn't it? It's a really, really invidious choice. And just as the Declaration of the Rights of Man tends not to have perhaps the resonance in English-speaking countries that it certainly does in France. So likewise, the civil constitution of the clergy. I think if you said, you know, what's the key moment in the French Revolution, I certainly wouldn't have said this. But it's amazing when you read histories of the revolution,
你知道，这是一个立法清理的过程。但对许多神父来说，这是一种彻底的痛苦，因为他们现在被置于许多人一直努力避免的境地，他们必须在宣誓效忠革命，或者保持对教皇、教会、上帝的权威的忠诚之间做出选择。这是一个巨大的时刻，不是吗？这是一个非常、非常令人痛苦的选择。正如《人权宣言》在英语国家可能不像在法国那样具有共鸣一样。同样，《教士公民组织法》也是如此。我想如果你问，法国大革命的关键时刻是什么，我肯定不会说是这个。但当你阅读革命史时，这很令人惊讶，
English histories of the revolution. Again and again, historians point to this as being the key moment that fractures the revolution, fractures any sense of kind of national harmony. So this is Simon Sharma. The civil constitution was not simply another piece of institutional legislation. It was the beginning of a holy war. William Doyle in the Oxford History of the French Revolution. The French Revolution had many turning points, but the oath of the clergy was unquestionably one of them, if not the greatest. And Peter McPhee in his brilliant Liberty or Death book on the French Revolution. The oath fractured both the church and the revolution.
英语版的革命史。历史学家一次又一次地指出，这是导致革命分裂、导致任何国家和谐感破裂的关键时刻。这就是西蒙·沙玛的观点。《教士公民组织法》不仅仅是另一项制度立法。它是圣战的开始。威廉·多伊尔在《牛津法国大革命史》中写道。法国大革命有许多转折点，但教士宣誓无疑是其中之一，如果不是最伟大的一个的话。彼得·麦克菲在他关于法国大革命的杰作《自由还是死亡》一书中写道。宣誓使教会和革命都分裂了。
I remember doing this at A-level, Tom, and the civil constitution of the clergy I regarded as incredibly boring and dry and everybody kind of skipped it because we couldn't wait to get onto the terror. But I think you're quite right to emphasize it because this does feel like the moment when what has been kind of one process carrying a lot of people along with it, when it really divides. I mean, that tension has always been there and that sense of an incipient kind of division between us and them, between the people who are on the side of the patrie or the nation and those people who are traitors or conspirators. But this is the moment that drives a lot of people
我记得我在A-level课程中做过这个，汤姆，我当时认为《教士公民组织法》极其枯燥乏味，每个人都跳过了它，因为我们迫不及待地想进入恐怖时期。但我认为你强调它是非常正确的，因为这确实感觉像是那个一直带着很多人前进的过程，真正分裂的时刻。我的意思是，那种张力一直存在，那种在我们和他们之间，在站在祖国或国家一边的人与那些叛徒或阴谋家之间，那种潜在的分裂感。但这是那个时刻，它驱使许多人
who might otherwise have gone along with the revolution against it because they are being asked to rip up everything they held, not just dear, but everything they held sacred. And a lot of people just will not do that. There are the faintest echoes of the Brexit referendum for us in Britain. Because effectively it comes to serve as a referendum because priests obviously pay attention to what their flock think. And the division is quite kind of Brexit-like. So 54% of priests end up taking the oath, which means that 46 don't. And there are very clear geographical divisions. So in Paris, the oath-taking is very high in the regions around Paris. In Provence, it's very high. but in the countryside and particularly in the West,
本来可能支持革命的人转而反对它，因为他们被要求撕毁他们所珍视的一切，不仅是珍视，而是他们认为神圣的一切。很多人就是不会那样做。这对我们英国人来说有英国脱欧公投的微弱回声。因为它实际上起到了公投的作用，因为神父显然会关注他们的羊群的想法。这种分裂非常像英国脱欧。所以54%的神父最终宣誓，这意味着46%没有。而且有非常明确的地理划分。所以，在巴黎，宣誓率非常高，在巴黎周边地区也是。在普罗旺斯，它非常高，但在乡村，特别是在西部，
essentially you have what has now emerged as a counter-revolutionary bloc. And you have people who are defining themselves as citizens and you have people who are defining themselves as Christians, as communities of souls. And both sides come to increasingly cast the other side in the darkest possible light. So enthusiasts for revolution see their opponents as people who are clinging onto superstition and privilege and all kinds of things like that. Whereas enthusiasts for priests who've taken the oath see revolutionaries as bloodthirsty fanatics who are destroying everything that has made their life precious. And it's the moment where you get counter-revolution as kind of the opposite to revolution. And it's the moment where you get counter-revolution as kind of the opposite to revolution. And it poses the question of, could it have been different? I mean, might
本质上你拥有了现在出现的反革命集团。你拥有定义自己为公民的人，也拥有定义自己为基督徒、作为灵魂共同体的人。双方都越来越倾向于以最黑暗的眼光看待对方。因此，革命的狂热支持者将他们的对手视为沉迷于迷信和特权以及诸如此类事物的人。而那些宣誓神父的狂热支持者则将革命者视为嗜血的狂热分子，他们正在摧毁使他们生活变得珍贵的一切。这是你得到反革命作为革命对立面的时刻。这是你得到反革命作为革命对立面的时刻。它提出了一个问题：事情本可以不同吗？我的意思是，可能
the revolution have been able to take the vast mass of Catholic citizens with them? And I know of no better kind of teaser for that question than a famous painting. It was done in 1789 in the wake of the drawing of the Declaration of the Rights of Man by a painter called Jean-Jacques François Le Barbier, who had actually been a court painter to Louis XVI. And in the wake of the signing of the Declaration, he is employed to give it a visual representation. So he gives all the kind of the favorite symbols. So there's, you know, broken chains and there's a liberty cap and there's great Masonic eye gazing down. But the thing that's striking about the portrayal of the declaration itself is that it is written as though it is carved onto stone tablets. And the stone tablets, of course, are an echo of the
革命能够带着广大天主教公民一起前进吗？我知道对于那个问题，没有比一幅名画更好的预告了。它完成于1789年，在《人权宣言》起草之后，由一位名叫让-雅克·弗朗索瓦·勒·巴比耶的画家创作，他曾是路易十六的宫廷画家。在宣言签署后，他受雇为其提供视觉表现。所以他给出了所有那种最喜欢的符号。所以有，你知道，断裂的锁链，自由帽，还有俯瞰的大共济会之眼。但关于宣言本身的描绘，引人注目的是，它被写得好像是刻在石板上一样。当然，石板是
tablets that were given to Moses on Mount Sinai, which is the kind of the definitive expression of divine revelation, not of human law. And of course, a prefiguring, Tom, an important and interesting prefiguring of Ed Miliband's stone tablets in 2015. Yeah, so the echoes of the French Revolution reverberate everywhere. So when Le Barbier is doing that, what is he doing? Is he saying it's possible to synthesize the Bible and the Enlightenment? You don't need to choose between them. The two can merge. And if that's what he's saying, I mean, it's not completely mad because actually it's very clear when you look at the Enlightenment that a lot of the values that the Enlightenment assumes are universal,
摩西在西奈山上得到的石板的回声，这是神圣启示的最终表达，而不是人类法律的表达。当然，汤姆，这是对2015年埃德·米利班德石板的一个重要且有趣的预兆。是的，所以法国大革命的回声在各处回荡。所以当勒·巴比耶那样做时，他在做什么？他是在说，将圣经和启蒙运动结合起来是可能的吗？你不需要在两者之间做出选择。两者可以融合。如果这就是他所说的，我的意思是，这并不完全疯狂，因为实际上当你观察启蒙运动时，很明显，启蒙运动所假设的许多普世价值，
that everyone would accept, are actually bred from deeply Christian assumptions. I mean, people who've listened to this podcast regularly will be aware. Have I ever heard you use that phrase before? Like you should have a Tom Holland generator where you just press a button and it says bred of deeply Christian assumptions. I know, I know. But just to give an example, say Voltaire, his horror at the fate of Jean Calin, why is he so upset by this? Why is he upset by the torture to death of an innocent man or an instrument of torture? It clearly reflects kind of deep psychological response to the figure of Christ that Voltaire would have absorbed as a child, I think.
每个人都会接受的，实际上是源于深刻的基督教假设。我的意思是，经常听这个播客的人会知道。我以前听过你用那个短语吗？就像你应该有一个汤姆·霍兰生成器，你只需按一个按钮，它就会说“源于深刻的基督教假设”。我知道，我知道。但举个例子，比如伏尔泰，他对让·卡拉斯命运的恐惧，为什么他对此如此不安？为什么他对一个无辜的人被折磨致死或折磨工具感到不安？我认为这清楚地反映了伏尔泰作为孩子时吸收的对基督形象的深刻心理反应。
Maybe, or maybe he just doesn't like people being broken on the wheel by torture. I mean, is that not possible? But there you're assuming that that's something instinctively that people react against. I mean, I think the evidence suggests contrary wise, I think plenty of societies have been perfectly happy with that. And Calais himself on the wheel, I should add, kind of makes this parallel explicit. I die innocent. I do not pity myself. Jesus Christ, who was innocent, died for me by even more cruel torments. And I think what kind of brings this home is the fact that Calais is exonerated by the French king, the anointed king, Louis XV. And he's exonerated not because Louis XV has become an Enlightenment philosoph, and not because the vast mass of people in France who feel
也许吧，或者也许他只是不喜欢人们被刑轮折磨。我的意思是，那是不可能的吗？但你在假设那是人们本能地会反对的东西。我的意思是，我认为证据表明恰恰相反，我认为许多社会对那种事情感到非常满意。而且卡拉斯本人在刑轮上，我应该补充一点，明确表达了这种平行。我是无辜而死的。我不怜悯自己。无辜的耶稣基督，为了我死于更残酷的折磨。我认为真正让这一点深入人心的是，卡拉斯被法国国王，受膏的国王路易十五平反了。他被平反不是因为路易十五成为了启蒙哲学家，也不是因为法国广大同情卡拉斯的人民成为了启蒙哲学家并同情伏尔泰的怀疑论，而是因为他们认为伏尔泰的运动与基督教原则完全一致。所以引用大卫·比恩的话，他写了一本关于卡拉斯事件的精彩著作，认为启蒙运动的影响使法国思想两极分化，创造了两个相互怀疑的大群体，一个是教权派，另一个是反教权派，这是将革命的发展（那里确实发生了）读回到一个根本不存在这些发展的时期。我们谈到了神父在革命最初几周和几个月里扮演的角色。在巴士底狱，这个充满锁链的阴暗地方，如果故事可信的话，以及为那些参与
sympathy for Calais have become Enlightenment philosoph and in sympathy with Voltaire's skepticism, but because they see Voltaire's campaign as being entirely concordant with Christian principles. So just to quote David Bien, who wrote a brilliant book on the Calafere, the view that the impact of the Enlightenment polarized French thought, creating two large, mutually suspicious groups, one clerical and the other anti-clerical, is to read back the developments of the revolution, where it definitely does happen, into a period when they simply were not present. And we talked about the role that priests play in the early weeks and months of the revolution. And at the Bastille, this storming of a place dank with chains, if the stories are to be believed, and the funerals that are given for those who had taken
风暴巴士底狱的人举行的葬礼，巴黎大主教宣讲的文本来自保罗。你们，我的兄弟们，被召唤去自由。这是一个情感，巴黎大主教宣讲的文本来自保罗。你们，我的兄弟们，被召唤去自由。这是一个情感，与革命中对自由的呼唤完全一致。所以汤姆，你实际上是在说，一些听众可能会认为这是经典的霍兰策略，法国大革命内部的意识形态斗争，革命者反对反革命者，基本上是两种不同基督徒之间的斗争吗？是的，我基本上是在说这个。我认为这是关于革命试图从
part in the storming of the Bastille, the text that is preached by the Archbishop of Paris comes from Paul. You, my brothers, were called to be free. And this is a sentiment that is preached by the Archbishop of Paris, comes from Paul. You, my brothers, were called to be free. And this is a sentiment that is perfectly in tune with the call to liberté in the revolution. So Tom, are you effectively saying, and some listeners may consider this the classic Holland gambit, that the ideological struggle within the French revolution, of revolutionaries against counter-revolutionaries, is basically a struggle between two different kinds of Christians. Yes, I am basically saying that. And it's about the attempt, I think, of the revolution to appropriate much of its inheritance from the
基督教过去中挪用其大部分遗产的尝试。我认为这是解读勒·巴比耶画作的另一种方式，它绝不是说圣经和启蒙运动、基督和伏尔泰可以被综合。它是说，一个革命秩序必须尽可能地挪用以前革命秩序的东西。事实是，我认为西方欧洲社会有一些独特的东西，可以追溯到宗教改革之前，一直追溯到11世纪，当时欧洲的原始革命发生，天主教会指导着它。你有一个让国王谦卑的教皇。
Christian past. And I think that's the other way of interpreting Le Berbier's picture, is that it's not in any way saying that the Bible and the Enlightenment, Christ and Voltaire can be synthesized. It's saying that a revolutionary order has to appropriate what it can of previous revolutionary orders. And the truth is that there is something distinctive, I think, about European society in the West that reaches right the way back beyond the Reformation, back to the 11th century, when Europe's primal revolution happens, where you have the Catholic Church directing it. You have a Pope who humbles kings.
基督教的过去。我认为这是解读勒贝尔比耶画作的另一种方式，它绝不是说《圣经》与启蒙运动、基督与伏尔泰可以融合。它是在说，一种革命秩序必须尽可能地挪用先前革命秩序中的可用部分。事实上，我认为西方欧洲社会有一种独特之处，它一直追溯到宗教改革之前，回到11世纪，当时欧洲发生了原始革命，天主教会主导了这场革命。当时有一位教皇，他让国王们俯首称臣。
The humbling of kings is a vital part of the dynamics of what is going on in the 11th century. You have an emperor kneeling in the snow before a pope. You have a notion that society itself can be born again, can be bred anew, can be washed in blood and emerge as something new. And it creates a kind of division within society that by the time of the revolution has been framed as being religious and secular. And of course, the Catholic church is the universal church. So that instinct on the part of the revolutionaries to preach universalism is a highly Christian one. And finally, just on the declaration that we began with, the declaration of human rights, where did the idea of human rights come from? If they're universal, they are not evident in antiquity. They are not evident
君主的卑微是11世纪社会动态的重要组成部分。你会看到一位皇帝在教皇面前跪在雪地里。人们有一种观念，认为社会本身可以重生，可以重新孕育，可以在血泊中洗礼并焕然一新。这在社会内部造成了一种分裂，到革命时期，这种分裂已被界定为宗教与世俗之争。当然，天主教会是普世教会。因此，革命者宣扬普世主义的本能是非常基督教化的。最后，就我们开头提到的宣言，即《人权宣言》而言，人权的概念从何而来？如果它们是普世的，那么在古代并不明显。它们并不明显
in parts of the world beyond Latin Christendom. They emerge in the 12th century as a product of the cultural ferment of that first revolution in Italy in the 12th century. And that's where they come from. So if the revolution is to proclaim that these are universal and that the revolution embodies them, it needs to utterly incinerate and obliterate the memory of that. And I think that what the revolution demonstrates is actually the one thing a revolutionary hates more than a reactionary is a rival revolutionary. And I think the hostility between the revolution as it will emerge over the course of the period that we've been talking about, so into the period of the terror, is that the hostility of the revolution towards the Catholic
在拉丁基督教世界之外的世界其他地区。它们出现于12世纪，是12世纪意大利那场第一次革命文化激荡的产物。这就是它们的来源。因此，如果革命要宣称这些权利是普世的，并且革命体现了这些权利，它就需要彻底焚毁和抹去那段记忆。我认为革命所证明的其实是，革命者最痛恨的不是反动派，而是竞争对手。我认为革命在这一时期，也就是我们一直在谈论的时期，一直到恐怖统治时期，革命对天主教会的敌意
church is similar to the hostility that Protestant reformers felt towards the papacy. It's kind of a rival church. It's a rival. Yes, exactly. Yeah, interesting. The Holland gambits are never more brilliantly deployed, Tom, than just now. Oh, you're very kind. So all of that lies ahead because we will get to the terror and the sort of civil war within the revolution. But obviously, right from the start, go back to the Declaration of Human Rights. That was what, August 1789?
与新教改革者对教皇制度的敌意类似。这是一种竞争对手教会。它是一个竞争对手。是的，没错。是的，很有趣。汤姆，霍兰式的策略在此时此刻运用得最为巧妙。哦，你太客气了。所以这一切都在前方，因为我们将谈到恐怖统治以及革命内部的内战。但显然，从一开始，回到《人权宣言》。那是1789年8月，对吧？
And right from that point, Louis and Marie Antoinette and the people who have not fled, who are still around them, they don't like this kind of stuff at all, do they? Of course not, because it has implications for the monarchy as well as the church. So Louis published a response to the declaration in September and he said, yeah, I love the spirit of it. Great. And then he went through all the specifics and said, don't agree with that. Yeah. So like the Serbian reply to the Austrian ultimatum. Yes. Very good. And I think for me, the obvious problem that they have with their constitution building and their desire to set France on a new sort of even keel is that they have a huge hole
从那时起，路易十六、玛丽·安托瓦内特以及那些没有逃跑、仍然留在他们身边的人，他们一点也不喜欢这种东西，对吧？当然不喜欢，因为它不仅对教会，对君主制也有影响。所以路易十六在九月份发表了对该宣言的回应，他说，是的，我喜欢它的精神。很好。然后他逐一审视了具体细节，并说，不同意那一点。是的。就像塞尔维亚对奥地利最后通牒的回复一样。是的。非常好。对我来说，他们在宪法建设以及希望让法国走上新轨道方面面临的明显问题是，他们的宪法中心有一个巨大的漏洞
at the center of their constitution, which is the king, because they've been talking about a British-style constitutional monarchy. But is Louis going to play that part? I mean, is he ever psychologically ready? And particularly once the church, which he has sworn an oath to uphold, once that comes into the kind of firing line, I don't think he's ever going to adjust himself to this new world. And obviously, we're going to get back to the narrative because just a few weeks after that, after his response to the declaration, that tension will reach a climax, won't it? With one of the most dramatic, exciting, tragic episodes of the entire revolution.
那就是国王，因为他们一直在谈论英式的君主立宪制。但路易十六会扮演那个角色吗？我的意思是，他在心理上准备好了吗？尤其是当他发誓要维护的教会一旦进入那种交火线，我不认为他能适应这个新世界。显然，我们将回到叙事中，因为在那之后仅仅几周，在他对宣言做出回应之后，那种紧张局势将达到高潮，不是吗？伴随着整个革命中最戏剧性、最激动人心、最悲剧的事件之一。
And that's what we're doing tomorrow, Tom. It is. It's the Women's March on Versailles. Very exciting. I can't wait. So we'll be looking at that and the way in which the revolution has to work out what it's going to do about the monarchy. So we will be back with that tomorrow. Au revoir. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
这就是我们明天要讲的内容，汤姆。是的。是凡尔赛妇女大游行。非常令人兴奋。我迫不及待了。所以我们将关注这一点，以及革命必须如何处理君主制的问题。所以我们明天会回来继续讨论。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐余波》
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
这是你们每周的娱乐新闻评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。